[Music]
season 1 of Netflix's stranger things
was an instant hit combining the mystery
and frights of early Stephen King with
the adventurous wonder of early Steven
Spielberg the powerful 11 is clearly a
nod to King's novel firestarter and its
1984 film adaptation
while the Spielberg references are
absolutely off the charts with at least
a half-dozen visual images to ET alone
the Dafoe Brothers new classic is so
deeply entrenched in 1970s and the 1980s
sci-fi and horror nostalgia in fact that
nearly every scene contains a wink and a
nod to one of the show's many influences
but the story and characters are so
engrossing a lot of the more obscure
references can go entirely unnoticed for
example x-men in stranger things first
episode justin challenges well to a bike
race for the loser has to give up a
comic book of the winners choosing when
will wins he shouts the exact issue he
wants as he rides off 1980s x-men issue
134 is the one where Jean Grey the
x-men's powerful psychic becomes Dark
Phoenix a cosmic being was dangerous and
unstable psychic powers this reference
for shadows the arrival of 11 a girl was
some mighty powerful psychic abilities
of her own twin peaks in the disturbing
final scene of the season will excuses
himself from dinner to go to the
bathroom where he vomits up a creepy
otherworldly slug his reality flickers
away and he briefly enters the upside
down the scary alternate dimension he
was trapped in all season as he stares
himself in the mirror above the bathroom
sink the implication here is that the
ordeal may be over but he's brought a
little bit of it back with them this is
similar to the final shot of David
Lynch's bizarre TV masterpiece Twin
Peaks when agent Dale Cooper smashes his
head into a bathroom mirror and cackles
maniacally after escaping the alternate
dimension in Twin Peaks the eerie black
Lodge alien stranger things has filled
with visual references from the Alien
franchise particularly in the creature
design of the demo Gorgon the most
direct reference however comes in the
final episode of the season when Nancy
sees Jonathan being pinned to the ground
by the creature
it's a gender swap to reference with a
bit more bite to the classic scene in
aliens when Ripley in nuzzled in a power
loader fires off a similar order at the
alien queen as it slowly approaches Newt
get away from her you [ __ ] the alien
references don't stop there
when joyce finally finds her son well
after traveling to the upside down
she and harper after put a large
serpent-like creature from his throats
listen wanted guests as likely the
source of the slug will pukes up in the
finale making it eerily reminiscent of
the face huggers from the Alien
franchise they live when the duffer
brothers of Steve and Jonathan gets into
a surprisingly brutal back alley brawl
over the graffiti shaming of Nancy
they're not just capturing two teenage
boys releasing their pent-up
frustrations on each other's faces with
their fists they're also paying homage
to the iconic absurdly drawn-out
back-alley battle between rowdy roddy
piper and keith a david in john
carpenter's 1989 classic they live
except in stranger things
it doesn't take special glasses to see
the real threat and the cops show up and
pry Jonathan off altered states stranger
things makes direct visual references to
1980s altered states with its use of
sensory deprivation tanks along with
other more subtle nods the tanks take a
prominent role in the cult science
fiction classic as William Hurt
psychologist character uses them and
powerful drugs to explore the limits of
consciousness it's much like how eleven
uses the tanks and stranger things both
willingly and against her well
to amplify her psychic powers so she can
make contact with the upside down The
Goonies towards the end of the season
there's a subtle reference to the scene
from The Goonies where joint discovers a
walk-in freezer filled with ice cream
and a dead body in the Fratellis
basement
and they got Jack with a ruptured in
stranger things
Dustin similarly discovers a
refrigerator filled with pudding cups
the lunch lady was hoarding but no dead
body in a school's cafeteria and gates
and Matarazzo delivers his lines a lot
like junk I knew she was hoarding it
knew it oh it's lying sink out plug this
liar by either chocolate thanks for
watching click the loop icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
your love to
[Music]